[Musique]
austin peterson bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
seulement 1% des américains vivent dans
l'iowa
expliquez-nous le rôle de cet état dans
la présidentielle américaine et le
premier caucus de l'année c'est donc
sans avoir besoin de plus bon test pour
les élections c'est très souvent le cas
car à la démographie de loi est très
large et représente beaucoup de
philosophie d'une logique politique dans
les états unis des régions presque
toutes les régions rurales
on peut avoir plus de soutiens pour des
citoyens urbains
on a aussi beaucoup d'universités dans
cet état donc il y aura beaucoup de
jeunes y soutient louis président du
candidat bernie sanders
il ya également beaucoup de zones
rurales et les électeurs qui vont avec
eux ont tendance à choisir des candidats
plus modérés comme claude bouty dieng
en quoi la loi au fond reflètent ils
vraiment la diversité nationale s'était
uni depuis leur fondation sont dans un
charisme entre
des états du sud plutôt agricole et un
autre plus tôt donc les valeurs
dépendent de cela et cela dépend
également du doubs les électeurs vive
que ce soit dans des zones urbaines ou
plus rurales pour les etats unis c'est
un conflit très lointain très long qui
se reflète dans les partis en fonction
de l'origine des candidats de la côte
est ou de la californie par exemple ils
auront des valeurs différentes que des
électeurs du midwest du budget vient du
midwest c'est également un vétéran de
l'armée
et bien qu'il soit ouvertement
homosexuel qui parfois peut poser
problème dans le midwest
il est très apprécié par les générations
les plus âgées où les démocrates qui
sont progressifs mais qui sont reste
modérée dans certains autres gens se
dessinent leurs candidats préférés
la trump se débrouille très bien dans
les régions rurales dans l'eau big wave
tant d'autres dans des régions qui ne
sont pas comme la californie ou du new
york
on retrouve ces deux types d'idéologie
il ya des régions rurales et des régions
industrielles
alors on dit que les cocus sont de plus
en plus impopulaire pourquoi pas
d'accord que ce week-end les gens aiment
les copies ce parce que cela récompense
il est candidat game la base électorale
est dynamique il se présentera pour
voter remporté un caucus il faut que les
électeurs soient dévoués qu'ils soient
prêts à rester pendant des heures et des
heures sur les lieux alors qu'ils
attendent le décompte des votes
il ya également un plusieurs séries de
vote au cours de la journée et je pense
que c'est une belle façon de déterminer
la région géographique et la philosophie
des électeurs vis-à-vis de leurs
candidats les candidats qui minent ne
sont pas viables qui n'ont pas atteint
le seuil électoral y laisser leurs voix
à des candidats secondaire c'est une
bonne chose de pouvoir voter pour le
candidat qui préfèrent et ensuite pour
voir choisir d'autres qu'on préférait
sinon alors qui selon vous pour
affronter donald trump côté démocrate en
matière de ressources
j'ai dit et je ne suis le plus important
en matière d'élection car j'ai couru
deux fois et je n'avais pas cela je me
dirais que michael bloomberg a les
ressources et à les aider afin de
concourir
le problème c'est que les sondages sont
en sa défaveur la prochaine et le nevada
ainsi que joe biden il ne réussit pas à
prendre les devants car nous le suggère
il est très possible pour empêcher ses
deux genoux les candidats j'imagine
qu'ils vont essayer de trouver des
accords en commande et je sais qu'elle
pourrait se retrouver le véritable
candidat c'est vraiment la seule
personne qui les ressources financières
et la réputation qui nécessaires afin
d'obtenir beaucoup d'électeurs aux états
unis alors il ya eu le procès en
destitution donald trump on en a
beaucoup parlé
est ce que c'est un avantage un
désavantage pour donald trump selon vous
a pas beaucoup de désavantages enfin je
pense que son plus grand défi c'est
compte twitter mais cela peut être
facilement résolues
s'agissant des avantages d'une entente
dans ses opposants les etats unis sont
très heureuses de cette façon c'est que
ces actions de donald trump qui sera
très difficile pour les démocrates de
proposer des politiques économiques qui
sont totalement opposées à celle de
donald trump tout en me disant que je le
fais il est très rare aux états unis
qu'un changement majeur intervient
maintenant en règle générale c'est très
important et réel aux états unis font
des primaires démocrates sont en fait en
marge de la réélection de donald trump
mais d'un point de vue objectif se
sentent que ce sera le cas
alors pour conclure en hameaux quelles
vont être les prochaines étapes
importantes de cette campagne commencée
le yorkshire
après le caucus de joie ce sera une
primaire simple testera un type de jeu
débouté différent bien que bernie
sanders remporter ces primaires certains
me disent je classe est intéressante
le cycle électoral sera la réaction du
parti démocrate face à dernier salaire
s'ils commencent à engager engranger des
victoires les causes possibles importe
trois quatre voire cinq frères et qq ce
alors la convention nationale paniquera
et j'ai sans doute
stratagème se mettre en place d'empêcher
leur nez sanders d'être avoir
l'investiture
merci beaucoup et austin pedersen
d'avoir partagé votre analyse en direct
sur rt frange rappelle que vous êtes
écrivain et activiste politique